françois hollande je veux dire vous
faire une confidence le débat a continué
pendant réalité on parle est
effectivement dans l'éventualité d'un
service civique ou du rétablissement du
service militaire à l'arrêt m'en voulais
rajouter quelque chose en compagnie face
aux problèmes de la jeunesse aujourd'hui
25% de jeunes qui n'ont pas d'emploi
peut-être plus c'est pas le service
civique qui règlera le problème même
s'il peut effectivement mettre 10
sparadrap là vous ça fait plus mal il
faut effectivement une vraie politique
économique pour l'emploi dans ce pays
parce qu'on va à la catastrophe et pour
le service civique qu'il faut demander
leur avis aux jeunes notamment parce que
qui leur a demandé leur avis exactement
aujourd'hui sur l'utilité sur le nombre
show là la définition les objectifs
derrière parce que si c'est pour faire
du service civique pendant six mois il
se retrouvait avec eux rien on doit ne
cesse de chômage pour les former on a on
avance dans l'exécution un mot fadila
khattabi sur françois hollande
parce que vous fait énormément de
reproche à françois hollande cette
conférence de presse et en se faisant
l'avocat du diable
il monte dans les sondages françois
hollande est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
est devenu président de la république et
qu'il n'était pas avant il a toujours
été le président de la république et
pour les français je les vois là on lui
a reproché beaucoup de choses
effectivement de ne pas avoir pris le
costume présidentiel d'être nous de ne
pas prendre des décisions or il a
démontré en tous les cas c'est vrai
suite aux évènements dramatiques de
janvier qu'il était tout à fait à la
hauteur tout à fait à la hauteur
il a pris le ton juste pour gérer cette
crise et 80 % des français pensent que
cette crise a été gérée par françois
hollande de manière remarquable
moi je me souviens écoutez je veux pas
lancer la polémique ici mais d'un
ministre de l'intérieur à avoir mis le
feu aux banlieues pour avoir tenu quand
même certains propos pas digne d'un
ministre de l'intérieur
donc je parle bien sûr de nicolas
sarkozy c'est par les scoops
donc voilà est là aujourd'hui il est y
fait des propositions il fait des
propositions en matière de développement
économique avec le pack de
responsabilité avec le cic pour donner
pour donner effectivement
de l'oxygène aux entreprises vous
devriez plutôt applaudir vous même au
niveau de l'ump certains disent ya des
avancées non on ne vote pas s'il ya des
avancées
ça veut dire qu'effectivement c'est
quand même cédé avancer ce sens mais
selon son site une loi de recul social
bon c'est un jour sans je ne vais pas
vous laisser parler valois macron je
vous préviens de suite mais un mot oui
soit présent la république tous les bus
puis après on abordera le dernier thème
de notre émission qui est important que
dans l'actualité
non mais de le président de la
république n'a pas changé effectivement
il bénéficie de sondages plus favorable
parce que je le reconnais il a bien géré
la situation au moment de la crise et
tant mieux on ne peut que s'en féliciter
également sur milices de l'intérieur et
son premier ministre
je le dis aussi sur cc collective mais
le mais le président a pas changé
écoutez son attitude pendant des cinq
conférence de presse qu'il a tenue
depuis depuis deux ans il a toujours eu
la même attitude
je vous avais annoncé ça mais finalement
ben oui j'y suis pas arrivé la preuve
l'emploi on est content au niveau de
l'emploi c'est quand même 20% de
chômeurs de plus depuis qu'il est arrivé
les a310 jijel et éditeurs la dette
vous savez que depuis ce matin on en a
on s'est endettée de 200 millions
supplémentaires ont pris parce que je
veux qu'on passe à l'est est juste que
c'est il avait annoncé l'inversé la
menti aux français est aujourd'hui moi
je vais je veux bien qu'on n'ait pas
fait ce qu'ils ont voulu
je veux bien madame français mais il n'a
pas menti aux français établis
je veux bien que les résultats n'est pas
forcément été à la hauteur de ce que
vous espériez de 2007 à 2012 la
situation est critique ce qui a été
annoncé en 2012 a dit c'est tout
l'inversé
non je suis à la tête d'un etat en
faillite c'est bien monsieur fillon je
me tournais un an je voulais vous allez
nous parler de l'année sinon on va pas
sinon on va pas en parler me reste
qu'une émules non je voudrais quand même
ajouté hollande
il en écrit alors s'il vous plaît je
vous laisse pas parce que christian
launay attendus tout à l'heure pour
parler donc vous attendiez de la romance
et voulait réagir sur françois hollande
et françois hollande dans les sondages
vous voulez passer de 17% à 22 ou 25
on peut pas dire que ce soit le
mirobolant 1 c'est pas le symbole de la
cohésion nationale
non ce qui a réglé le problème c'est le
miz l'intérieur et le gg ipn et le gign
ici coin et donc les jambes raides
c'est vrai derrière vous pour qu'on
parle à la fin de cette émission de ce
qui va se passer demain tout près d'ici
dans le doubs deuxième tour de la
législative partielle pas un très bon
moment pour l'ump rennie de lattes
puisque c'était le premier test
électoral post charlie comme disaient
certains observateurs
l'ump était devancée et puis il ya eu
cette grande difficulté de choix pour
l'ump qu'est ce qu'on fait par rapport
aux deux candidats qui restent en lice
il ya une jolie vache rit du quotidien
libération ce matin vous avez peut-être
vu la lune j'ai prévu la une la une
cette l'errance d'arabie pour parler de
lui au palais nicolas sarkozy écoutez
moi je suis très serein très serein
parce que quand j'analyse les résultats
du doubs je vois que l'ump entre 2012 et
l'élection de dimanche dernier progresse
de 3 points quand le parti socialiste
baisse de 9 points
aujourd'hui savez vous que dans le doubs
un électeur sur neuf fait confiance au
candidat du veau en fin qui représente
la majorité gouvernementale 1 sur 9
on n'a jamais vu ça jamais vu ça donc je
me satisfais pas des résultats que je
viens d'évoquer pour autant l'ump l'ump
depuis 2012
il ya eu en france 13 partiel
législatives même père n'a gagné 12 6
dans une 13e 12e
dimanche dernier il y avait deux grandes
élections partielles également pas
partiel pendant deux 2 grandes élections
donc municipal toutes les deux gagner
quelque chose que vous parlez chiffres
moi je vous propose un autre chiffre
à leh pour relancer le débat et puis
après tout les autres répondront en 2010
32 % des sympathisants de l'ump était
favorable à des accords locaux avec le
front national
aujourd'hui le chiffre est à 55% des
sympathisants de l'ump qui sont prêts à
des accords locaux avec le front
national
est ce que c'est ça qui explique la
difficulté de choix de l'ump depuis
dimanche sur ce qui ce que leurs
électeurs doivent faire dire la
difficulté de choix moi je vais être
très clair sur la ligne h 2 mais
attendez la première formation politique
de france doit avoir un débat au sein de
deux de ses instances c'est tout naturel
s'il n'y avait pas de débat que ce soit
le chef qui dit c'est comme ça on dire
ah ben voilà c'est tout ce qu'on veut
pas un parti démocratique
nous on a eu un débat moi les choses
sont très claires
aujourd'hui quel est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une grande formation
politique qui doit donner des consignes
de vote à ses électeurs non parce qu'il
faut respecter les électeurs et je
comprends je comprends les des électeurs
qu'ils aient pu porter leurs voix sur le
front national par dépit par par rejet
de certaines situations que l'on peut
comprendre aujourd'hui quelle est la
position pour ma part c'est sûrement pas
possible aujourd'hui de soutenir à paris
un parti qui est l'ump l'ump va quand
même pas dire on vous invite à voter
pour le front national
madame le pen n'a que deux mots assez
durs pour contre l'ump
deuxièmement un parti qui a une
politique absurde une politique
politique absurde sur l'économie j
comment voulez-vous journée
il accède en effet remis n'est qu'après
que ce n'est pas bon le nimitz vous donc
vous ne vous attendez attendez une
politique qui voudrait nationaliser
l'ensemble des banques françaises une
politique qui voudrait que l'on sorte de
l'euro n'est pas pour le candidat
démocrate c'est bien on a compris
comment voulez-vous aujourd'hui que
l'ump soutiennent soutient un candidat
candidat qui appartient une majorité qui
laissera les missions faute à des
christian launay savons que vous soyez
un peu énervée ni de la xive ou grecs
attendent et je dis pas non il devrait
durer 4 minutes et vous aurez vous
grimpez soutienne un candidat qui se
réclament de la majorité c'est vous qui
réclament de l'amazone vous plaît je
vais l'amener mentale et christian
launay la consigne les crises on aurait
pu vous c'est la confusion de lattes
c'est l'extrême confusion plus personne
ne s'y retrouve et s'assigne de fedor ya
peu de chefs c'est la guerre des chefs
et deuxièmement il ya plus de médias
plus de programmes via plus de messages
or je crois que les français ont besoin
de s'identifier avec un programme clair
un axe clairement définis et de
s'identifier aussi et qu'une avec une
personne qui l'incarnent qui incarne
leadership c'est marine le pen qui
incarne le qui représente l'unité la
cohérence et l'autorité voilà je pense
que c'est ça dont les français ont
besoin et si c'est la conclusion de
l'émission qu'on va faire pas tout à
fait eh bien je pense que votre votre le
maquis dans lequel vous vous êtes en
foncé va pas vous perdre
alors alors donc évacuer le doubs avec
tout le respect qu'on lui doit
demain il ya une élection voulait passer
parce que c'est simple faut battre
l'extrême droite
un point c'est double que les états
d'âme de l'ump moi je m'en moque
complètement faut battre l'extrême
droite dimanche c'est clair non les
frelons premièrement parce que nous
avons une eau bien d'autres problèmes
que de parler des eledees dame à
l'intérieur de l'ump dans une société
bloquée dans une société qui s'enfonce
dans la crise une crise très profonde
qui demain va s'accentuer l'insee nous
promet cent mille chômeurs de plus
donc on arrivera à 6 millions la rave
l'annexé contentement sociale ne vous
profite pas électoralement comme jamais
assez c'est comme ça que je vise
williams il ya un énorme problème dans
cette société effectivement d'un monde
libéral avec une pensée libérale défendu
à longueur de journée deux chaînes de
médias qui sont entre les mains
d'ailleurs des grands financiers si cela
qu'il faut régler dans une dans un pays
qui s'est mis les menottes et la
camisole de force avec le traité
européen
tant qu'on aura ce traité l'attend qu'il
fonctionnera comme ça on pourra rien
faire laisse répondre je ne suis pas
indifférente à ce qui va se passer
dimanche pour la simple et bonne raison
que c'est une région que je connais je
suis né à montbéliard et j'ai eu mon bac
à montbéliard donc je ne suis pas du
tout indifférente la situation la
position du parti socialiste elle est
claire c'est pas la politique du ni ni
nous soutiendrons systématiquement le
candidat démocrate
et si cela doit si cela dit tout ça
c'était ce récipient démocratie si cela
ce jeudi je n'ai jamais terminé monsieur
le nay 6,7 cela doit se réitérer et
probablement puisque nous avons quand
même des échéances au niveau
départemental quand même qui arrivent là
dans quelques semaines c'est clair nous
voterons pour le candidat ump si c'est
un duel ump fn ce n'est pas un citoyen
c'est pas un fantasme chinois une
réalité vous à la main ces décisions non
mais vous vouliez de la clarté nous
sommes clairs nous avons une position
la tente de dévier de la démago la
position dure mais c'était la confusion
s'est pas dites moins démocratiques des
millions d'électeurs a représenté par
deux députés à l'assemblée nationale
c'est démocratique c'est un autre débat
un autre de namur ont donné le sondé
tracy porter commencer par balayer c'est
un autre débat dames et messieurs
permettez moi de vous dire c'est juste
ce que les français ne veulent plus vous
êtes en train de parler de contingence
deux parties qui n'intéresse personne
qu'est ce que veulent les gens donnent
ce qu'ils rejettent la politique et
rejoint aussi être un échange est la
politique du gouvernement actuel c'est
clair et aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut faire
et c'est sur quoi travaille dur l'ump
réunit aujourd'hui en conseil national
est en train de préparer un projet qui
soit capable demain d'assurer
l'alternance mais pour le président je
suis sérieux les élections et qui
revient qui revient alors que le
candidat le président hollande autrement
dit qu'il ne se représenterait pas à la
présidentielle signe des noces de
résultats au niveau du chemin est fait
et je me suis coupé parce qu'il reste
lui seconde c'est la fin d'émission
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat très
riche très intéressant et très vives
bon week-end
oh